vous voulez vous voulez un débat le plus
restreint possible même vos collègues
qui avaient des amendements c'est la
secte Jones des amendements ils saute
suicide tous
et quand on a un amendement qui porte
sur la question de des bonnesifications
pour les agents de la fonction publique
ou des majorations de durée d'assurance
pour les femmes du secteur privé même
pas celui-là vous voulez qu'on discute
même pas celui-là un 8 mars mais vous
vous rendez compte ce que vous faites
mais c'est plus c'est plus c'est une
honte
c'est plus c'est plus ce que vous nous
quand tu permets c'est plus
l'application du règlement c'est plus
l'application du règlement c'est une
volonté délibérée de faire taire
l'opposition par tous les moyens y
compris sur les sujets parce que la
personne va le dire nous expliquer qu'on
est hors sujet que ces contradictoires
qu'on peut pas en parler et tout à
l'heure sur les amendements de Monsieur
Savary on aura le droit de s'exprimer ou
faire comment on fait on fait un mot au
Président Monsieur le Président
pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît nous dire
si on aura le droit de s'exprimer je
vous remercie beaucoup de votre
attention c'est ça l'idée c'est de nous
humilier en plus mais c'est pas nous que
vous humilier c'est les femmes toutes
les femmes
merci
merci chers collègues monsieur